(dramatic music)
- So what should we do Gary V?
Let's wrap this up, what should we do?
What should people do?
- People should fucking stop complaining.
- [Interviewer] Right, good,
good call. - People should
figure out who the fuck they are.
- [Interviewer] Good call.
- [Gary V] People should not listen
to America propaganda of
fixing the shit they suck at.
They should be tripling down
on what they're good at.
They should be competent in certain areas,
but you're gonna become Beyonce
or, ya know, like your bone
structure is a certain way.
Like you're not gonna solve everything.
Your IQ can get a little bit better,
but don't worry about the incremental.
Figure out what you
fucking puts you on fire,
and you're halfway decent at.
If you're lucky enough
right now to be listening,
and you're good at what you like,
become tunnel fucking vision.
Because there's way too
many voices telling you
what and how, and here's the other thing,
and this is the big one now,
because you have a humongous audience.
The biggest thing that
I've seen dividends from:
have the conversation with the person
that's holding you back.
The reason most people who
are listening right now
are not doing that thing,
is they're worried about
the opinion of somebody.
Usually, their mother, their father,
and the reality is, is that you're spouse
may be the person holding you back
and you have to have that conversation.
We have to get to a place
where you're doing you
because the number one thing that scares
the fuck out of me is regret,
and you're going to sit there at 72,
and you're gonna say, "I
wish, I wish, I wish."
and whether that's money,
or spend more time with your family,
there's a million ways to do this.
Not everybody wants to buy the Jets,
not everybody wants to smoke weed
on the beach in the Bahamas.
Like everybody's got a
different fucking thing,
figure out what your fucking thing
is and stop making
fucking bullshit excuses,
Who the President is, your mom did this,
like, like "I missed it,"
"I had that idea for Uber,"
then why didn't you fucking do it, dick?
(intense music)